and remarkably little has been done about it.
If you're a wizard, and you think that clean, abundant,
carbon-free nuclear power is key to fighting climate change,
then you have to worry
that the public willingness to build nukes is going down.
If you're a prophet, and you think that the solution to the same problem
is these neighborhood-run solar facilities shuttling power back and forth,
you have to worry that no nation anywhere in the world
has devoted anything like the resources necessary to develop this technology
and deploy it in the time that we need it.
And if you're on either side, wizard or prophet,
you have to worry that, despite the massive alarm about climate change,
the amount of energy generated every year from fossil fuels has gone up
by about 30 percent since the beginning of this century.
So, still think we're different than the protozoa?
Still think we're special?
Actually, it's even worse than that.
(Laughter)
We're not in the streets.
No seriously, if there's a difference between us and the protozoa,
a difference that matters,
it's not just our art and science and technology and so forth --
it's that we can yell and scream, we can go out into the streets,
and, over time, change the way society works,
but we're not doing it.
Wizards have been arguing literally for decades
that nuclear power is key to resolving climate change.
But the first pro-nuke march in history occurred less than two years ago,
and it was dwarfed by the anti-nuke marches of the past.
Prophets have been arguing, again literally for decades,
that conservation is key to keeping freshwater supplies
without destroying the ecosystems that generate those freshwater supplies.
But in the history of humankind, there has never been a street
full of angry protesters waving signs about leaky pipes.
In fact, most of the political activity in this sphere
has been wizards and prophets fighting each other, protesting each other
rather than recognizing that they are, fundamentally, on the same side.
After all, these people are concerned about the same thing:
How are we going to make our way in the world of 10 billion?
The first step towards generating that necessary social movement,
creating that critical mass and getting that yelling and screaming going
seems obvious: wizards and prophets join together.
But how are you going to do this, given the decades of hostility?
One way might be this:
Each side agrees to accept the fundamental premises of the other.
Accept that nuclear power is safe and carbon-free,
and that uranium mines can be hideously dirty
and that putting large volumes of toxic waste on rickety trains
and shuttling them around the countryside is a terrible idea.
To me, this leads rather quickly to a vision of small,
neighborhood scale, temporary nukes,
nuclear power as a bridge technology while we develop and deploy renewables.
Or accept that genetically modified crops are safe
and that industrial agriculture has caused huge environmental problems.
To me, this leads rather quickly to a vision of plant scientists
devoting much more of their attention to tree and tuber crops,
which can be much more productive than cereals,
use much less water than cereals, and cause much less erosion than cereals.
These are just ideas from a random journalist.
I'm sure there's a hundred better ones right here in this room.
The main point is,
wizards and prophets working together have many paths to success.
And success would mean much more than mere survival,
important though that is.
I mean, if humankind somehow survives its own outbreak,
if we get food to everybody, get water to everybody,
get power to everybody,
if we avoid the worst effects of climate change,
if we somehow safeguard the biome,
it would be amazing.
It would say, I think,
even to a hardened cynic like me,
maybe we really are special.
Thank you.
(Applause)